alright so up next we have generated
Jennifer Johnston who's actually one of
Yale's own and we've invited her today
to talk about her work here at Yale and
some of the mechanisms so we've talked
about assessment we've talked about
prediction and prevention but a lot of
the questions also remain about what are
the underlying reasons some people make
suicide attempts and some people do not
and so Jennifer is going to talk with us
today about her research here and when
the labs at Yale I'm she's a researcher
she's also a clinician private practice
here in the area with expertise and
emotion regulation difficulties and
suicidal behaviors and youths and adults
so in the sake of time I will go ahead
and let her talk a little bit about what
her research is so please joining me in
welcoming Jennifer Johnson
[Applause]
okay I was told that if i turn the
microwave with the microphone off it's
on me to turn it back on so the first
thing is successful I turned the
microphone on and everyone can hear me
thank you so much I'm leap for the
introduction and I am just so excited to
be here today because I've actually been
an attendee this conference in years
past and just really think that Emily
and Seth and everyone involved here in
the NDA PPD in at you do such a
marvelous job of really putting on such
a high quality educational conference
for us each year and so I'm excited to
be a part of that this year and I'm also
excited to be able to share with you
some of the more recent research that we
have in regards to the neural circuitry
underlying suicidal behavior because I I
really is a passion of mine to be able
to speak in settings like this where
we're kind of trying to bridge that gap
between research and practice right
because that's what research is supposed
to do is to help us apply things in
clinical settings so I'm glad to be able
to speak here and I thought it would
might be helpful for me to give you just
a little bit of background about myself
and kind of how I came to be here just
to provide some context so my background
actually started out much more clinical
my my graduate program they're certainly
the the idea of link between biology and
symptom and brain and behavior and
that's where my interest in research
began but I trained in dialectical
behavioral therapy and then worked for
several years in clinical intensive
outpatient outpatient settings and I
never really lost sight of my interest
in research though and I think this
really crystallized for me one day I was
sitting in front of the clients of mine
it was very highly suicidal at the time
and she just looked at me and she said
why am I like this and really what she
was asking was why was she thinking
about killing herself because she
understood that she had a lot of friends
and a lot of peers who were struggling
with things at home
at school and yet they weren't thinking
about killing himself and she wouldn't
understand why and I knew that I can
answer her question in part based on
psychological theory my knowledge about
her past and if i was really good i
might people say something to the effect
of like well there are neurons and stuff
you know but i couldn't answer her
question any more detail than that and i
knew that i wanted to so that's when i
contacted dr. Hillary Bloomberg here at
the mood disorders research program at
Yale and asked her if I could can learn
about and contribute to her research
here and God bless her she said yes and
I've been here for about four years and
I'm really excited to share some of what
I've learned and what we've really
studied in our group here at Yale so
today I will be talking about the
neurobiology of suicide with an emphasis
on neural imaging and to do that I'll
start out with just a little bit of a
synthesis on the prevalence and
development of suicide behaviors as it
applies to my talk today then I'll give
you just a little bit of an overview of
some of the methods used in neuroimaging
and what they've told us then about
suicide behaviors across all diagnoses
in general from there we'll drill down
into the very specific diagnosis of
borderline personality disorder and look
at which of these findings might be
related to this diagnosis and then we'll
look at how these findings might compare
across other psychiatric diagnoses and
i'll just use the work being done in our
group and the focus of my research in
bipolar disorder as one point of
comparison and then lastly I'll try to
look at how your imaging might help us
understand and prevent suicide and how
we can use our understanding of some of
the neural circuitry in more clinical
settings in a clinical application so
again all of us here today realized as
soon as that is a very serious and
growing problem and we've heard a lot of
statistics today so I'm not going to go
through more just a couple that apply to
what I'm going to talk about here today
so we've heard now a few times that more
than 40,000 Americans will die by
suicide each year and that actually
means that in 2014 someone died by
suicide
read every twelve point three minutes
and in this slide it shows that in 2014
suicide was the 10th leading cause of
death in all Americans we've seen this
before but if we limit that to younger
age groups and as we've heard already
today in children ages 10 to 14 in 2014
so it varies a little bit but year by
year but it was a second leading cause
of death in children and adolescents
ages 10 to 14 and it remained the second
leading cause of death in 2014 in ages
15 to 24 and so these charts that I just
showed you weren't actually to scale so
to give you a better sense of how many
das might be attributable to suicide
within each age category I'm going to
show you a graph next that breaks it
down by the age interval and so what
really jumps out to me as I'm sure it
does to you is the dramatic increase in
number of suicides are a number of
deaths by suicide rather during
adolescence and young adulthood so it's
not just that it is the second leading
cause it's just but that there's a
dramatic increase during this time
period and yes as we saw later also it
still continues to rise and the risk
continues to rise later but there is
this increase during adolescence and
young adulthood and that gets even more
sobering when we consider that we know
that there are approximately 25 suicide
attempts for every one suicide and
adults ages 18 and over and then again
if we limit it to younger age groups
approximately 100 to 200 attempts for
every one suicide in young adults ages
15 to 24 so why am i emphasizing this
again and besides the fact that it
underscores the suicides a very serious
problem that can't be ignored the fact
that there is an increase a number of
suicides during adolescence and young
adulthood really suggests that there
this is a really critical developmental
period for the development of suicide
behaviors and so we want to think
critically about what's happening during
this time period and when we think about
adolescence then
were thinking about obviously a lot of
physical maturation and growth and
puberty we're thinking about the many
effects that the hormones can have on
the brain body we're also thinking a lot
about social developments and identity
development and the many perils that can
exist in our interpersonal relationships
during this time period as I'm talked
about in dr. King's talk but what we
also know is that this is actually a
very critical period for brain
development beginning and adolescents
and on into young adulthood and this
suggests in part then that suicide
behaviors along with some of it we've
shown in other studies other risky
behaviors might be able to be linked to
specific neural mechanisms and this
really is what neuro images are trying
to do it's a big task but we're trying
to understand the biological mechanisms
underlying the development and the
maintenance of suicide behaviors so to
begin to understand how to do that I
want to give you I think it's helpful
just have a little bit of a sense of
some of the methods that we use in their
imaging and looking at what they have
told us about suicide behaviors across
all psychiatric diagnosis so far so when
we think about studying the brain you
can really kind of focus in on looking
at it in two different ways you can look
at the structure of the brain or what it
does or how it functions and then within
each of these two categories we have
different methods as well so when
thinking about structural we can look at
the gray matter like in this picture and
this essentially helps us look at the
brain anatomy so the different size and
shape of different structures like the
red and yellow tray structures there and
the technique most often used to look at
this is magnetic resonance imaging
alternatively you can look at white
matter which essentially is the
myelinated axons that provide
connections between the different brain
structures here's a picture of what that
might look like a more recent technique
to look at white matter is called
diffusion tensor imaging it's a really
exciting technique because it helps us
look at very specific white matter
tracts and
the brain and understand their
structural integrity or how well there
may be able to conduct signal and here
is a picture of an example of one
specific white matter tracks in the
brain and I like this picture i think is
pretty cool it's a lot of a different
white matter tracks in the brain so we
can use these structural techniques then
to compare the anatomy of the brain
between groups like between people who
attempt suicide and people who don't
attempt suicide and look at whether or
not the structural integrity might
different between these two groups again
we can also look at how the brain
functions and we have other techniques
here the first I'll talk about is
functional magnetic resonance imaging
essentially this really just kind of
helped us understand which neurons of
the brain might be firing at any given
point it helps us understand how the
brain might be responding to specific
tasks or stimuli that we give them while
they're in the scanner other fMRI
techniques allow us to look at which
regions of the brain might be kind of
coordinating their action over time or
communicating with one another for
example in this image this is a region
of the brain during a scanning protocol
that is coordinating with the amygdala
which is an emotional center of the
brain then we have radio ligand based
studies the first is single photon
emission computed tomography and that's
quite a mouthful so I prefer SPECT
because that's easier and then we have
positron emission tomography or pets and
these allow us to tag water or glucose
molecules and understand how the brain
is functioning and these are also used
occasionally to probe different
neurotransmitter systems as I'll talk
about later today so as an example in
this picture the areas of red and yellow
or areas of decreased serotonin turn on
receptors actually so then using some of
these techniques what have they told us
about suicide behavior so far before we
do that though I just really want to
make sure we're oriented to the pictures
I'm going to be showing I'm so this is
obviously a brain with the different
lobes of the brain and you can see it's
oriented as if I were standing sideways
with a fun of the brain to your left and
the back of going to your right and if
you were to cut the brain from top to
bottom you'd be able to see the internal
structures of the
brain and the brain can be divided into
more dorsal regions or areas towards the
top of the brain and more ventilations
or regions towards the bottom of the
brain all right so now that we're
oriented let's look at what the studies
have shown us about suicide behavior and
I'm going to start with some structural
findings and in the recent review
written by our group we looked at all of
the studies looking at suicide
attempters across across all studies and
what we really saw within was a
convergence of evidence implicating more
frontal systems and this included the
dorsal prefrontal cortex the ventral
prefrontal cortex the amygdala and also
other anterior limbic which is kind of
more emotional type connection sites
also we saw convergence and evidence in
the white matter that connects these
structures and so these studies were
mostly in adults but they're also with
some overlap with adolescent samples
which suggests somewhat of an early
Genesis and again these areas of the
brain are developing during adolescence
and young adulthood and so also are
their functions then so is a little bit
of an example kanna broadly the dorsal
prefrontal cortex has been linked to
executive functioning behavioral control
type things so we can see you maybe
understand how adolescents might have a
little bit more difficulty with
long-term planning and inhibiting
certain behaviors so that doesn't really
sound like any of the adolescents that
you work with whereas ventil regions
just relatively they might be more it
might be more involved in emotion
regulation and motivational behavior and
again we might be able to point to how
adolescents may have slightly more
difficulty with these things than
perhaps older adults to the eventual
prefrontal cortex is highly connected
with more of the limbic emotional sites
that includes the amygdala which is an
emotional Center and is very involved in
emotional responding the hippocampus you
may know is involved in memory related
processes including laying down
emotional memories and the insular
cortex is is a really complex structure
and it's kind of talk
underneath the frontal and temporal
lobes and among other things it's
involved in internal monitoring of our
effective and physical states so if we
move on now to some of the functional
findings we see a lot of overlap with
the structural finding so again this is
how the brain is now functioning and
that means that we sell a lot of
findings in this frontal system and this
was during specific tasks so during the
processing of angry faces and happy
faces these aren't the real faces shown
but it gives you a little bit of a sense
and also during tasks that involve
impulse regulation so during risky
gambling choices or motor inhibition
tasks we saw abnormalities in these
frontal regions as well in attempters
then we also saw a decrease in blood
flow and glucose metabolism in these
frontal regions showing somewhat of a
hypo function of these regions and as I
mentioned before some studies using
radio like and measures can probe
certain neurotransmitter systems and the
neurotransmitter system most often
studied in suicide is a serotonin system
so in this side we're looking at the
synapse or serotonin neuron and that's
the space between two neurons so we have
the neurotransmitter is generated in one
neuron is released into the synaptic
space it can connect with a receptor oil
and opposite neuron and it can also be
taken back up via the original known
here this transporter here and so
studies and attempters have shown us
that there are abnormalities in the
serotonin system in the synthesis of
serotonin in the receptor binding and
also the transporter binding so that's
great that we can identify these
regional abnormalities but what might
actually mean for us and how does it
relate to the symptoms that we're seeing
and this is where it gets a little bit
more complicated because up until now
I've been talking about suicide as if
it's a very homogenous concept as if
every attempter and a group of attempter
is the same
and of course we know that's not true
and we also know that what
differentiates attempters within one
diagnostic category could be very
different than what might differentiate
someone in a different diagnostic
category we already saw a dr. Stanley
kind of point out the difference between
people who may be struggling versus
borderline personality disorder and this
makes it very difficult than to
determine who might be most at risk for
suicide so as many of the speakers have
already pointed out today I think it's
very important when we're talking about
suicide to remember that it exists on a
spectrum all the way from possibly a
passive desire for death to actually
ideation of hurting oneself to the
actual behavior and suicide and when we
think about this then there are also
constructs that we want to be careful to
consider within this spectrum so if
we're looking at ideation some of the
things we might be thinking about our
anhedonia we might be thinking about
decreased cognitive flexibility or the
ability to think of other options
besides suicide and we might be thinking
about hopelessness if we get over to
behavior the constructs might shift a
little bit maybe now we're thinking
about constructs like impulsivity
negative emotional reactivity and also
the lethality of actions because
actually a lot of researchers have
argued that high lethality attempters
are those who make the most lethal
attempts could represent a very
different subgroup than the low
lethality attempters with high lethality
tempters sharing much more in common
with those who actually complete suicide
and so we will want to be careful about
thinking about lethality of actions as
well as maybe some of these other
constructs if we want to contextualise
and understand the general brain
findings and if we do that if we try to
understand these neural imaging findings
in the context of suicide we can look at
the general functions of the brain
regions where we see the abnormalities
and then we can also try to start to
draw some associations between those
abnormalities and
clinician administered rating scales of
symptoms and behaviors or other self
reports so it's just a brief example of
this if we see a structural abnormality
in the ventral prefrontal cortex like I
had shown you we might then start to
think that perhaps this implicates
emotion regulatory processes then if we
want to understand better how the brain
might be responding to different
emotional cues we can introduce a task
into the scanner and get some functional
findings so we might then look at the
neural response to emotional face cues
if you think back to a couple of slides
ago I'd shown you the that we did see
abnormalities in that frontal system
when responding to both positive stimuli
and negative stimuli and then we can go
a step farther and think about maybe
some form of self-report or other
clinician administered scale and just
one example if we're looking at emotion
regulation might be the difficulties in
emotion regulation scale and there's
there's aa backs to each of these
approaches but they're really important
for a step to help us better understand
some of our findings that we see in the
biology and just to illustrate this if
we go back to that serotonin side
certainly again we've seen the
abnormalities in the serotonin synthesis
receptor binding and transporter binding
but we've also seen associations between
impulsivity and transporter binding and
hopelessness and receptor binding and so
this gives you a sense of how we can
take one specific symptom that we see in
the clinical room and link it to a
lonely a brain region because it was in
frontal brain region specifically
ventral but also to potentially in your
own transmitter system and that's that's
the Holy Grail that's what we'd like to
be able to do so let's keep these things
in mind and we're going to move now into
looking at some of the results related
to borderline personality disorder so
actually despite the prevalence in
borderline personality disorder there's
been very little neuroimaging research
perhaps that has to do with funding so
again go sign that petition but I want
to focus on one 2002
study that looked at the gray matter
structure in the brain and individuals
with borderline personality disorder and
what they saw is that in comparison to
controls BPD attempters had less gray
matter and areas that are involved
broadly in emotion regulation executive
functioning and behavioral control so
this included the ventral prefrontal
cortex including the orbital frontal
cortex or the ofc that's the area right
above the eye orbits and is the ventral
most component of the PFC also involved
reductions in the hippocampus and
parahippocampal or around the
hippocampus and the insular cortex among
some other regions so now we have these
brain abnormalities let's think about
function so the orbital frontal cortex
is involved in behavioral control as
well as emotion regulation so we can see
how that would impact suicidal behavior
also the hippocampus as i said is
involved in memory but there's actually
been some studies to say that attempters
may have more difficulty with certain
retrieval of autobiographical memories
specifically the positive
autobiographical memories and what this
means is that these individuals may have
more difficulty than envisioning a
future positive outcome based on their
past experience and this could use the
others might contribute to I'm thinking
that suicide might be the best option in
this moment the insula as I mentioned is
really quite complex that has a lot of
connections with the ofc the amygdala
hippocampus and other connection sites
and is involved among other things and
again the internal monitoring of
effective and physical states including
pain I think this one is really
interesting because you hear a lot of
clients coming in talking about just
very visceral feelings of pain involved
in the emotions that they are
experiencing in and around suicide
attempts and the other interesting
aspect of function that the insula has
is that it's related to mirroring
responses and others amiran emotional
responses and others so these authors
were also interested in looking at some
constructs that I had mentioned and they
focused on lethality of attempt in his
particular study so they took their
attempt to a group and I broke it down
into high lethality and low lethality
groups and looked at how the two groups
might differ and how these results in
the overall attempter group might
compare within this subsample and what
they saw actually is that high lethality
attempters differed in many of the same
regions from low lethality attempters as
the overall group did from controls and
this included the ofc and insula also
the pair hippocampus which isn't only
pictured here so I didn't list it but
really what this tells us then is that
structural abnormalities may be able to
differentiate between high lethality and
low lethality tempters at least in this
diagnosis and that's really important if
we consider our hypothesis that perhaps
high lethality tempters share more in
common with people who complete suicide
if we ever want to get to a place of
identifying people more at risk and
again people can shift between low
lethality and high lethality attempts
but it's a start to begin to unpack risk
factors first later suicide attempts so
again these areas are broadly involved
in emotion regulation behavioral control
and executive functioning and that can
represent this biological vulnerability
or some of the mechanisms behind this
vulnerability but oftentimes it's not
this isn't enough in order for there to
be a suicide attempt there's also
usually a proximal trigger correct that
and I understand that again people with
borderline personality disorder will
often have really chronic ideation for
years and years and we certainly can't
underestimate the effect of long-term
stressors like childhood maltreatment
but I also think that if you look
closely an attempt there's often a very
more recent trigger and what we've heard
about today actually in a couple of the
talks then is that interpersonal
difficulties are often to trigger for
people with borderline personality
disorder and the reason this is very
interesting is that actually the
structures that I just spoke about
which had those functions and those
other functions that I mentioned also
are implicated in interpersonal
responding so the ofc is important in
responding to individuals either
impulsively or not impulsively and also
the insula in particular is associated
with things like cooperation rejection
sensitivity and self and other awareness
or empathy so if we go back to the first
talk today dr. cainnes talk she spoke a
lot about this idea of perspectives that
taking for self and others as being
important in borderline personality
disorder and I kind of perked up because
I was like well that lapse on lovey
because the insula actually has some
rules in that exact thing and this was a
finding in their study and might be
something that we want to be thinking
about in relation to suicide and
borderline personality disorder the
other thing that I found quite
interesting is again the original
comparison was in all attempters for
borderline personality disorder compared
to controls but they also looked at
attempters versus non attempters in the
only structure that came up is different
was the insula and so this could mean a
lot of different things it might mean
that there are some shared vulnerability
for suicide across attempters and non
attempters and borderline personality
disorder just one example might be that
they share some vulnerability to emotion
dysregulation and behavioral control and
that would make sense given the
diagnostic criteria correct but it might
also mean then that perhaps those who go
on to make attempts if the insula is a
structure that might differentiate then
maybe these individuals have just
slightly more sensitivity to some of
these interpersonal struck difficulties
and simultaneously they might have
slightly more trouble identifying how
their behaviors might impact other
people and this is just one hypothesis
and would require a lot more study but
it's interesting for us to think about
when we're considering the all of the
talks that we heard today but in the
authors in hypothesized as suicidal
behavior and borderline personality
disorder can often be linked to these
interpersonal triggers and that
disruptions and the
ofc pocampus the influence and these
other structures might limit the brain's
ability to respond adaptively to these
particular kinds of social structures by
disrupting the functions of those brain
regions that would allow someone to
respond with different emotion
regulation strategies or to inhibit
their impulsive behavior and this is
really in line then with what's called
the diathesis stress model which was as
alluded to in a couple of tax which is
proposed by dr. john mayer nat of
columbia university and in this we have
a biological vulnerability and so in
borderline personality disorder this
would maybe be the ofc hippocampus
insula and these other related
structures and then this biological
vulnerability is impacted by things like
genetics but I didn't have a lot of time
to get into today but certainly genetics
can have an influence also the
environment factors childhood
maltreatment being just one example and
also hormones sex stress hormones having
being a couple of examples of this and
each of these can have an effect on the
neuro development of these brain
structures during adolescence and young
adulthood leading potentially to
structural abnormalities and also the
NAB normalities in the functioning of
those regions that might contribute to
risk for suicide and this is the
diathesis but again everybody with
emotion dysregulation is vulnerabilities
walking around dysregulated all the time
so there are tends to be a more proximal
emotional stressor again in the case of
borderline personality disorder and
maybe more often in a personal stressor
and this leads to a loss of cognitive
control through a disruption of the
functions of those regions that we saw
the structural abnormalities which leads
to an increased likelihood of impulsive
aggressive behavior self-destructive
behavior and potentially ultimately
suicide but again not everyone with
borderline personality disorder will
attempt suicide and certainly not
everybody has the same trigger or reason
for suicide but this is something for us
to kind of consider so in summary
BPD attempters had lower gray matter
volume and regions involved in emotion
regulation behavioral control executive
functioning and interpersonal responding
to social situations we also see them
that structural differences may be able
to differentiate between high and low
lethality subgroups and we see that it
is possible that during times of stress
may be particularly during times of
interpersonal stress the behavioural
functions of those structures are
disrupted leading and contributing to
suicidal behavior so now let's turn then
to how this might compare to two other
psychiatric diagnoses using the work
done in our lab and a focus of my
research on bipolar disorder as one
example so in thinking about how
borderline personality disorder might
compare with other diagnoses there's
actually been really few comparison
studies so there's not a lot to go on
that's really any diagnosis compared to
another diagnosis in this particular
field and also to complicate matters the
methodologies differ widely across
research sites so how one group might be
looking at very matter data could be
very different than how a different
group might be looking at grey matter
data or one group might be looking at
structure another at function and that
may make it difficult to draw
conclusions about the underlying
mechanisms and thus we don't know
exactly what might be shared
abnormalities across diagnosis and be
similarly targeted for treatment and
intervention and which might be unique
and require some more tailored
approaches and so essentially we kind of
don't know whether we were comparing
apples to apples or apples to oranges
here and so we have not had the chance
to do a direct comparison between
borderline personality disorder and
bipolar disorder that we'd really love
to but we did want to show in looking
bipolar disorder attempters and to look
at the neural mechanisms in this
diagnosis and that's what I'll share
with you and we really wanted to focus
on that developmental time period so we
looked at age
14 to 25 and like I had mentioned what
makes comparison difficult is that a lot
of groups will be using multiple methods
to look at suicidality within the same
sample and so we really wanted to use a
multi-modal approach to looking at this
and bipolar disorder and so we looked at
grey matter like the structure like I
shared with the borderline personality
disorder sample and then we also looked
at white matter we're using diffusion
tensor imaging which I talked about the
beginning of the talk to look at the
white matter integrity and we also
looked at functional connectivity or the
way different regions of the brain
communicate with one another and we
focus on connectivity than with the
amygdala which as I mentioned is an
emotional center of the brain I was
really involved in emotional responding
it's implicated in emotion regulation
and in other samples it's been shown to
see some structural abnormalities and
attempters so what we saw then was a
decrease in grey matter volume in the
ofc and hippocampus and the cerebellum
so I'm hoping that some of these brain
regions are starting to look really
familiar by now and that's because we
did indeed see some overlap with the
borderline personality disorder sample
and that we saw a reduction in volume in
the ofc and the hippocampus so this
would suggest even though is two very
different studies that there might
indeed be some shared vulnerability to
suicide behavior and if we think about
the functions of these regions maybe
that shared vulnerability is an emotion
dysregulation as well as in how memory
processes are used in the middle of
crisis and it also suggests that there
might be some areas of difference
because we didn't see a difference in
the insula and this I think is also
important because dr. Kane had talked
about the impairment and object
relations wasn't a general risk factor
but specific to a borderline personality
disorder and so again that research is
very separate and different but it is
interesting that potentially there are
general risk factors for suicide
behavior and there might also be very
specific risk factors within a diagnosis
then we went on to look at the white
matter and we saw connections
then the or reduction in white matter
integrity and structure called the
uncinate fasciculus and essentially this
carries major connections between the
orbital frontal cortex and the amygdala
and this would suggest then that there
might be some disruptions and how the
orbital frontal cortex is able to
communicate with the amygdala and vice
versa if the integrity is compromised in
this particular structure we then went
on to look at the functional
connectivity with the amygdala so how
again the brain regions are
communicating with one another and we
saw a reduction in connectivity between
the amygdala and the ventral prefrontal
cortex so taken all together the regions
of the brain that we were looking at the
task that we used in the scanner because
this was during the processing of face
stimuli and fearful happy and neutral
face stimuli as well as the findings
across modalities really implicates an
emotion regulatory system and circuitry
as important for suicide in bipolar
disorder which might make some sense
knowing what we know about the symptoms
of bipolar disorder and the high
extremes that they can have in their
emotions we also then wanted to look at
how these findings might relate to one
another and so we wanted to look at
whether or not there were relationships
between the structure and function
because it would make sense that white
matter might have an impact on how the
brain functions or that the structures
might impact functioning but we really
need to see some associations or
relationship before we can draw that
conclusion and so we did look at
associations between these findings and
also with some of these other symptoms
like hopelessness impulsivity lethality
of attempt and ideation and what we saw
then is that we did see an association
between the decrease in white matter
integrity and that uncinate fasciculus
that provides a connection between the
amygdala and the ventral prefrontal
cortex and the decrease in functional
connectivity between the amygdala and
the ventral prefrontal cortex and so
this might suggest a structure function
relationship and also suggest
perhaps it inhibits the ability of the
ventral prefrontal cortex to exert that
kind of top-down emotion regulatory
control over perhaps some hyper
responding to emotional stimuli in these
bipolar disorder attempters also was
very interesting is that we didn't see
associations with hopelessness or
impulsivity in this sample but we did
see that both of these areas of
difference in the white matter and the
connectivity we're associated with
suicide ideation and so this suggests a
mechanism of risk or how these structure
function abnormalities are contributing
to risk within this sample and the point
to illustrate this a little bit in
depressed used it's been shown that
maladaptive emotion regulatory
strategies actually increases suicide
ideation planning and action whereas
adaptive emotion regulatory strategies
can decrease suicide behavior so it is
possible that high emotion dysregulation
in these individuals contributed to by
these kind of neural mechanisms of the
abnormalities in the white matter and in
the functioning contribute then to an
increase in suicide ideation and thus
potentially to an increase in suicide
behavior also then as a it shows here
there was an association between that
area of reduced connectivity and attempt
lethality with those who made higher
attempts having even more abnormalities
and that connection with the amygdala
and this is consistent with other adult
studies showing hypofunction or reduced
functioning in the frontal networks and
is also consistent at least in the
region with the borderline personality
disorder sample that I showed you
because if you remember the ofc was
associated with had lower gray matter
volumes and those who made more highly
lethal attempts than those who made low
lethality attempts so again we're just
trying to begin to understand how to to
parse out and differentiate between what
is a really complex construct of
suicidality so in summary for borderline
or sorry for bipolar disorder then
sigh reductions in grey matter volume we
saw reductions in the white matter
integrity and we saw reductions in
functional connectivity between the
amygdala and the ventral prefrontal
cortex and we also saw connections
between structure and function with
white matter connected to the
connectivity and we saw associations
with particular symptoms ideation and
lethality and this together implicates
that ventral frontal limbic system and
thats observes emotion regulation is
important in bipolar disorder and again
a couple of things to point out then it
does also maybe give us a sense
preliminary sense of shared
abnormalities with water line
personality disorder and some
differences and we can begin to maybe
understand how we might be able to have
targeted treatments for some diagnosis
that's going to be later as we really
gain much more knowledge because this is
very preliminary but it's at least a
start to know that we can see the
underlying neural mechanisms for why
there might be differences and
similarities across these diagnostic
categories and also to point out again
this was in an adolescent subsample so
it gives us a little bit of a sense of
how the brain might be developing and
that link would then the development of
suicide behaviors during that time
period but what it doesn't tell us is
whether or not the children before we
got to this age actually had
abnormalities already and that those
might be predictive of later development
of suicide behavior or whether they
really started out very very similar
until they hit adolescence and then
there's this altered trajectory during
developmental time where there's
disruptions potentially in the neural
circuitry and their paths start to
diverge because that that makes a big
difference in terms of how we treat and
potentially prevent suicide behaviors
and adolescents and all in and to young
adulthood so from there it's kind of
sideways into how can neuroimaging help
us understand and prevent suicide
behaviors right now and how can we maybe
apply some of this understanding of the
neural circuitry in more clinical
settings
and so I think one of the big take-home
messages for you today is that we can
see neurocircuitry differences in
attempters and associated with
suicidality and I hope that I've shown
that today however or as we like to say
and EBT and we have not reached the goal
of identifying one particular risk
biomarker we cannot have someone going
to a scanner and look at like a
threshold of the volume and the orbital
frontal cortex and say this person is
going to be more at risk we're not there
yet and what's more likely because as
it's been pointed out this is such a
complex and very interrelated issue is
that there's likely going to be many
biomarkers including interrelated
systems as opposed to just one we can
also know that neuroimaging paired with
different assessment techniques like
self-report can help us clarify our
understanding of some of these brain
findings to help us more contextualize
these biological findings and how they
might contribute to risk however this
assessment is in really early stages the
the study that I showed you in
borderline personality disorder was the
first to my knowledge in borderline
personality disorder attempters and that
was in 2012 so it's been relatively
recent and it since it is in such early
stages one positive finding really
should not negate the possibility of
other positive findings and it's just
one example I'd mentioned the serotonin
system is the most widely studied in
relation to suicide but it doesn't mean
we shouldn't look in other places like
dopamine you know with reward processing
and look at potentially other
neurotransmitter systems which we have
which is not to the same extent and at
the same time since this is early they
should not be considered definitive
results even my own study but just as a
place to start that this is what we see
as kind of a first round and we really
need to refine our knowledge and our
understanding to get us closer to
understanding the biological mechanisms
behind suicide behavior and next
neuroimaging can show us that there may
be similarities and differences
the neuro abnormalities across diagnosis
and we do not fully understand how those
no American mechanisms work yet and how
they contribute to risk within and
across disorders and this will be very
important for us to understand as
clinicians if we want to really tailor
our responses to different individuals
and based yes on diagnostic criteria but
other criteria potentially as well is to
understand what really might be similar
indifferent in these biological
abnormalities in the individuals that we
treat so what can we do to help move our
field forward then and definitely we
need more longitudinal studies and
individuals known to be at risk for
suicide so I guess we saw it today that
we're not really sure who's at risk for
suicide but there are some things that
we can look at like those who are
experiencing suicide ideation and if we
follow those individuals over time we
can potentially look at neurobiological
predictors of attempts again to try to
understand is this structural
abnormalities or these functional
abnormalities there early in childhood
you know in the younger ones who are
already attempting or is this something
about the development and in altering at
the trajectory of development in these
brain regions and these neurotransmitter
systems that really contributes to risk
over time and we also need more
multimodal studies comparing the
similarities and differences across
diagnosis if we're ever going to try to
get to a place where we can really
tailor our responses and potentially
eventually maybe we can begin to target
neural circuitry in our treatment
approaches and design and look as
outcome measures some of these neural
circuitry and to illustrate that I just
want to quickly point out that actually
some treatments for borderline
personality disorder have shown an
effect on areas of the brain that are
implicated in suicide and this includes
the dorsal prefrontal cortex the ventral
prefrontal cortex the amygdala the
hippocampus and the insula among other
regions but the important thing here is
that they actually didn't look at
suicide or suicide behavior
as an outcome measure and this would
absolutely need to be directly assessed
before we can draw any kind of
conclusion about the effect on treatment
on neural circuitry and then in effect
on a reduction and suicide behaviors so
then if we don't have a biomarker and we
can't play someone in a scanner and know
whether or not they're more likely to
attempt suicide then what can your
imaging help us do today and I'd like to
give you some suggestions and it also
want to be clear that this is not
evidence-based treatment and that these
strategies haven't been gone through
randomized controlled trials and I think
that they can be helpful for some of the
patients that we work with and certainly
when I think about going back in time
and if I were sitting across from that
same patient that I talked about the
beginning of my talk these are things
that maybe I would have wanted to be
able to do with her and the first is
that I think that we can really explain
that there are biological including
neural vulnerability factors for why you
might consider suicide as an option and
the reason I think this might be helpful
and I'm thinking about that particular
client and I think the reason it could
help her is actually really struggled
with guilt and shame and that she as
well as probably many clients has been
told that thinking about suicide was
just a really selfish option and she
struggled with that and I think if we
understand that there might be
neurobiological underpinnings to these
symptoms like so many psychiatric
symptoms then it can start to alleviate
some of that guilt and shame and
potentially stigma and lead to increased
understanding invalidation among our
clients certainly also among peer and
family caregivers and those clinicians
for sure I also think then we can
explore how the neural mechanisms that
confer risk for one diagnosis and one
individual might be different from
individual to individual and that we can
take then a curious non-judgmental
stands to exploring these things with
our clients let's recruit them and
trying to understand how their brain
might be vulnerable and you might use
language like do you think
came back at that particular episode
that your brain might be more vulnerable
to just responding in ways that you'd
even want to respond to in that time or
that you struggle in just responding to
people in particular into this
interpersonal arena or is it really that
your emotions just start to feel
unmanageable and in that way then we can
really start to think about these
vulnerabilities and strengths because
there's along with vulnerabilities
there's a lot of strength in every
individual but they can be personalized
and it also is just a side note I think
for some individuals and this really it
requires some clinical judgement like
any technique that we use but the
slightly distancing language of talking
about do you think your brain might have
vulnerability for individuals who are
really high have very high shame it
feels somehow different then do you
think you struggle with emotion
dysregulation there's a couple of
individuals that I'm thinking of where
that's really helped them enter the
conversation into a slightly different
way when I got kind of stuck with them
when they were experiencing a lot of
high shame again it's not going to be
the same for every client we work with
but there might be something about
shifting up language a little bit that
might be helpful for some individuals
next we can encourage our clients that
the brain is plastic and able to change
and learn new ways of responding and
this is so important because it is not
that the brain is damaged that it is not
at all what we're talking about and it
is not there are vulnerabilities like
there's vulnerabilities to everything
people walk around with vulnerabilities
to cancer and two different other
symptoms and behaviors arranged from
psychological to physical there are
vulnerabilities but there's absolutely
the potential for change so we really
want to discourage that kind of
fatalistic thinking of like well this is
my brain and this is the way it's going
to be and it will always be and there's
nothing I can do about it no we want to
actually encourage that responsibility
for a change because what is true is
that these alterations and circuitry
don't happen overnight that probably the
circuitry that's seen many repetitions
when when engaging in suicide ideation
and behave
year over the course of this person's
life span is we're going to require many
repetitions of learning new ways of
thinking and behaving I was so grateful
for the talk earlier from the young
woman who shared because her story kind
of tells it she kept at it she kept
practicing and practicing and practicing
and that's how we can start to change
the neural circuitry is not going to
happen overnight and we can't do it for
our clients but we can encourage them to
begin to change the circuitry for
themselves and that really is the
message that we want to transmit is one
of hope because what I hope I've shown
you today is that there can be a link
between these the symptoms of suicide
and the behavior of suicide and
biological factors it starts with an
impact of genes and hormones and stress
both early and later stress that this
can impact neurodevelopment leading to
perhaps two abnormalities in potentially
a frontal brain system including gray
matter and white matter structural
abnormalities and function abnormalities
that might contribute to risk for
emotion dysregulation executive reduced
executive functioning and behavioral dis
control and ultimately to suicide but
this also gives us many points of
intervention starting potentially with
early childhood stress and stress
throughout the lifespan we can intervene
there maybe we can intervene during
neurodevelopment to steer these neuro
developmental trajectories back on track
maybe we can intervene with different
behavioral and psycho pharmacological
approaches to affect the structure and
function of the brain to have an effect
than on the symptoms and ultimately lead
to a reduction in suicide behavior so
with that then I'm going to end here I
really want to thank my research lab
there's so many people I really couldn't
list them all but I do think everybody
and also my clinical supervisors current
and past and some of the people from my
DBT consultation team who are here today
their clinical guidance and insight
really does inform the work here today
and so I'm very grateful so
[Applause]
thank Thank You Jennifer we have one
question that focuses on so a lot of the
researchers today cut talked about the
sense of self and maybe an unstable
sense of self were there any findings
with regards to suicidal risk that were
in regions that might overlap with how a
fluctuating sense of self is implicated
yeah and so broadly actually the insula
also would be involved in that sort of
the sense of self the monitoring an
awareness of yourself and other people
so it's an awareness of your sense of
self and also an awareness of other
people and the mirroring of emotional
experience and there can be other
associated brain regions but just in
terms of what I talked about today that
had come up in a particular study the
insula would be potentially involved in
processes like that ok wonderful thank
you so much Jennifer
[Applause]
[Music]